what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be re
reacting to a big video i can't talk
today
labeled hypergamy explained i've heard
this word
thrown around here and there and i'm
gonna be honest
i never said i was the sharpest tool in
the shop i don't know what that means
at all so i'm about to find out but
before i start
do not forget to like comment and
subscribe
i'm so close to 15 000 subscribers i'm
gonna hit it today i think
and yeah if you guys don't mind clicking
that subscribe button
helping a girl out i'd really appreciate
it
all right let me hyperd me
[Music]
all right so hypergamy this is a huge
subject and this is
really critical when it comes to the red
pill in general also
the feminine imperative this drives so
much in society
hypergamy is what most people just call
dating or marrying up
women typically date men a few years
older than themselves
who are often in a higher socioeconomic
class
okay now in a dating sense this
translates to being interactive blah
blah blah you get this
but i feel like men tend to date up in
looks
now here's the the the consequence of
modern dating
in feminism and women breaking the glass
ceiling as we talked about before
the higher up that women climb the
socioeconomic ladder
the smaller the pool of men above them
becomes
this is the the paradox of success when
it comes to women
can you imagine being tall too i can
i'm six foot but so for women and we
should probably put this in the women's
show at some point too because this is
really important
uh the fewer guys that are above them
the smaller that pool
of available men the date into true well
this drives a lot of the other stuff
that we talked about
uh the the law of hypergamy is
that women are most attracted to their
best
possible option that's available to them
period it is unfortunately with
the way society has kind of gone off the
rails a little bit
women will often compare their highlight
reel
to any guy they're going to judge in the
future so even though
a eight and a woman's maybe a six and
that eight could get
sevens and eights themselves sometimes
nines
that six now thinks she's entitled or
her bare minimum now is gonna be eights
from
there on in the future right but okay
guys we'll get super mad about this
right
uh mostly because women like are never
brought down to earth they should be i'm
gonna totally give guys that they should
be
but i'm sorry but if guys if the roles
were reversed right
and guys that were sixes had models that
were eights and nines
throwing themselves at them they would
probably overlook the sixes too i'm just
gonna
be real with you until they were two
brought down to earth this is how you
get alpha widows oh yeah
so this can really screw up women's
mating strategies long term and we've
seen this throughout society in all
kinds of examples
uh celebrities have terrible
relationship histories
and a lot of it becomes this kind of
thing they can't date regular people
because
they're used to the the cream of the
korean the creme de la creme
what i've noticed is there's two types
of like alpha widows
there's like one type that
will forever be mad at men blame men for
everything
and then there's the second type that
makes life changes
and takes accountability for her actions
and
actually ends up in an okay
or like good relationship after i don't
know i've just noticed that there's like
like one group will literally hate man
and one group will
make changes oftentimes like i i know
this because
i'm like in involved in church like i'm
christian
and like from my experience and that
i've seen like a lot of girls like take
accountability and make changes
the top-notch guys in society that top
10 55-10 percent
the celebrities chris rock has an
interesting comedy bit on this which is
that
men cannot go back sexually and women
can go back in lifestyle
right and so if they have access that
means the lifestyle has got has got to
move up it can't move backward
yeah that's absolutely true i can
definitely see it from a guy's
perspective
where you know once you've gotten a
woman of a certain physical
attractiveness that's going to drive
your standards in the future
or anything else is going to be a
letdown i can see that i'll i'll concede
that
but definitely from a relationship
perspective if they've like i said
before they've gotten
guys of a certain echelon before they've
shown that they can do it once
but they've never taken into account
that their looks are depreciating
uh what do they bring to the table well
the ego lies
to everybody the eagle will lie to
everybody and so women
will listen to the ego and they'll say
you know i i don't see any reason why i
can't be
you know sex in the city and just
pulling whoever i pulled in my 20.
does nobody have low self-esteem
where are my insecure [ __ ]
oh my god because anytime you go to a
bar or a club now it's
you look around everybody's at their
face their nose is buried in their phone
yeah there's no socializing going on get
used to back when we were kids
um i remember back in the day you went
to a club and that was
all you had was what was in that club so
you were only competing against your
local market
now with the advent of tinder match
okcupid and all this other [ __ ]
you're competing against all of the guys
in your entire geographical
area well did you know that the
psychology of choice
is that the more choices someone has the
less satisfied they are with their
choice
joe it's just the competition's never
been higher and
it's not going to change anytime soon so
you've got to really step up your game
i would say you were you were going off
on on this economic
tangent i love it but for some reason
the phrase the elasticity of demand
was like just stuck in my head and i and
i couldn't get that out
on this subject because hypergamy is
it's pretty it's a big subject
oh my god yeah but and in that it's it's
criticality to everything else
but as a term it's pretty
straightforward women date and marry up
that's all there is to it
economically but not physically no i
just i think it's so interesting that
practically you you you could
communicate this concept to a non-red
pill guy
a run-of-the-mill guy and they would
generally buy into it
and the thing is a lot of girls will
think that they're above
like a certain guy because they're
better looking but they don't take into
account like social status
and um
money basically well it's not a this is
a it's not a red pill term this comes
from psychology
biology and sociology and social
psychology was what i was trying to say
this is all okay this is
that's like the end of the clip um that
makes sense
i don't really have any extra thoughts
other than
i think a lot of guys get mad at this
concept but
if the roles were reversed i guarantee
they would do the same thing
except like looks right so like
if they grew up turned 16 right 16 year
old boy
grew up and eights and nines and tens
started throwing themselves like women
started throwing themselves
at the five sixes sevens
they probably did the same thing i'm
just saying um but let me know if you
agree or disagree with me in the
comments don't forget to like comment
and subscribe
especially subscribe to the channel
again
close to 15 000. you guys are my
favorite leave a comment
bye